we've managed to do it uh with very
little uh
obstruction on trade i understand the
frustration
in the fishing industry it's not what
they expected criticizing the
unpreparedness
of either the government or the european
union customs officials in terms of
uh getting everything up and running is
a little bit unfair it was in doubt
right
up to the last minute but on christmas
eve the eu and britain clinched a free
trade deal for the post-brexit era
now at least in the uk there are some
hard realities to deal with
and plenty of shouts of betrayal my
guest this week from aberdeen in
scotland is andrew bowie conservative mp
and vice chairman of the conservative
party why is boris johnson so economical
with the truth
and why did he break so many promises
[Music]
andrew bowie welcome to conflict zone
thank you very much very pleasure to be
here
i guess you can argue about whether
britain's 11th hour free trade deal with
the eu is good or bad but
whatever it is why did the prime
minister have to lie about it i'm
thinking about his
flat-out denial that there were
non-tariff barriers associated with the
deal
well i don't think that using uh phrases
like lie isn't anybody helpful i mean
what the prime minister was trying to
explain is that this was a a good deal
for britain a good deal for the eu and
the tariff barriers that were
uh in place were far
less of an obstruction that would be the
case if we hadn't got a deal
and all the scare mongering and the the
stories about the queues it's over and
the queues at cali and the hold-ups
have come as not and uh we are
proceeding in a relationship with the
european union that we want to see
uh flourish uh for trade for business
and for the peoples of both of our
uh both of our unions and i think yes
but you you you you gloss over a good
basis for that to move forward if i may
say you
gloss over the fact that what he said
which was on christmas eve
there will be no palisade of tariffs and
no
non-tariff barriers no non-tariff
barriers time to admit isn't it
that that simply wasn't true no i
wouldn't agree with that at all there
there are of course tariff buyers but
the prime minister that's not what he
said
that's not what he said so either he
either he didn't know or he wasn't
telling the truth
which is it i mean either he didn't know
he wasn't telling the truth which was it
and the pride
the prime minister's been absolutely
clear all the way along he was
determined to get a deal that worked for
the united kingdom out of european union
we got that deal it's a deal that's good
for business and provides a very good
uh starting point for uh for for the
relationship between
the european union and the newly
independent and sovereign united kingdom
uh to flourish and the tariff barriers
the paris that are
in place are not insurmountable that is
what the prime minister was trying to
say when he said there is no palisade
of of tariffs it means they are
surmountable we're working with business
to overcome the small hurdles the
teething problems that some of them
might be having at the minute
and so that we can move on uh into this
new era of friendship and cooperation
between the eu and the uk
well i hate to nitpick but he said there
will be no palisade of tariffs and
no non-tariff barriers and we now have
what retailers are calling
the biggest imposition of red tape in 50
years
and the uk tax authorities have
estimated that the cost
of that for british companies will be
around seven
billion pounds annually so to say that
there will be no non-tariff barriers i'm
sorry to keep going on about this but i
think the truth matters in politics
what it what does it say about a
government that leaves a false statement
on its website especially when it's
known to everyone that it is false
it shows a degree of contempt for the
british public doesn't it
i think that's out of the nonsense i
mean the prime minister in the british
government absolutely sure
uh nothing at all like in terms of
british public we treat them with a
great deal of respect and
and we we trust that they understand
that the deal that we've got is a deal
that's good for business good for trade
and and yes there are going to be
teething problems and yes there is red
tape at the minute and we're working
very closely with business
and by the way with the customs uh
organizations on the other side of the
channel within the european union to
to make sure that these uh obstructions
such as they are
are not in place for very long and that
the teething problems are
worked out the wrinkles are ironed out
and we're able to continue
uh freely and smoothly trading with the
european union as we were before we left
well let's talk about um some of the
teething problems as you call them a bit
later but the fact is that uh
the government has been less than candid
over much of the brexit process hasn't
it let's take the northern ireland
protocol
in october 2019 which mandated checks on
goods going from great britain to
northern ireland
because northern ireland is remaining
inside the eu single market for goods
two months later mr johnson insisted
there'd be no checks
why was that again ignorance or
dishonesty
no it was neither the prime we were
determined to make sure that when the
united kingdom of britain but northern
ireland left the european union we did
so as one and that's what we've done
uh whilst allowing the northern ireland
uh to have the best of both worlds
avoiding a hard border on the island of
ireland i think you'll agree that was
the last thing that
anybody wanted and so the compromise
that we came to was such
the the northern ireland would remain
within the eu customs union of course
that's going to involve
some uh elements of checks on trade
between uh the island great britain and
uh northern ireland yes but that's not
what he said he denied it what mr
johnson actually
said was there's no question of there
being checks on goods between northern
ireland and great britain
or great britain in northern ireland and
that was simply untrue
wasn't it no i wouldn't say it was
untrue
it doesn't accord with the facts it's
not untrue that's that's
this is so history this is sophie's
dream is the bowie
i i really say i think we what we've
achieved has been was was something
which most people
thought was unachievable uh nobody
believes i'm not asking
about that i'm asking about the children
who leave the transition period
as a whole with northern ireland
remaining as a part of the uk
single market and the eu customs union
without a hard border on the island of
ireland with trade
uh flowing just about as freely as it
was before
we left the european union i think
that's a great success
for the british government and indeed
for the european union who compromised
as well and we came to an agreement
that allowed the the uk as one to leave
and to respect the jurisdiction of the
republic of ireland over
goods uh on that island i i understand
that you don't want to talk about the
issue of truth and you'd much rather
talk about other aspects of this deal
but um look what happens look at the us
look at what happens when leaders no
longer bother to distinguish between
fact and fiction it can lead to massive
social dislocation aren't you worried
about that here in britain
well i think comparing the situation in
the united kingdom with the six years in
the united states we might be getting a
bit beyond ourselves
i mean i think that there's well it's
because of the lying isn't it it's
because of the lying that's gone on and
trump's refusal to accept the truth
i think there's a huge difference
between trying to explain the
complexities of a trade agreement
between the united kingdom and the
european union and accepting
the results of free fair and open uh
democratic election which is what we've
seen
in the united states of america and i
think i speak for just about everybody
in the conservative party and the
government when i say we are looking
forward to this wednesday and seeing joe
biden
uh assume the presidency of the united
states we can put to bed this era
of uh of lies deceit and falsification
of an open democratic process in the
united states of america
fact is um mr bowie that a lot of people
who
trusted mr johnson have been badly let
down haven't they
the democratic unionist party in
northern ireland said they were promised
they'd be treated
just like anywhere else in the uk and
they weren't a year ago
no i mean a year ago i just finished the
question can i just finish the question
a year ago mr johnson told us the
unionist
that no british conservative prime
minister could or
should sign up to any brexit deal that
damaged the fabric of the union with
regulatory checks and even customs
controls between great britain
and northern ireland and yet that's
exactly what the northern ireland
protocol did isn't it
fact as part of the single market
northern ireland has to follow strict eu
regulations
on food standards plant and animal
health that's fact
and that's exactly that's diametrically
opposed to what mr johnson promised them
yes but what uh yes exactly yeah
diametrically opposed
no but what the prime minister did
achieve he achieved the united kingdom
leaving the european union as one united
kingdom with the best of both worlds for
northern ireland and the alternative
was to leave northern ireland in a
position with a hard border on the
island of ireland
or uh we were almost in a situation
where the republic of ireland would have
controlled almost every aspect
of trade on the island of ireland you're
telling me
you're telling me yes you're telling me
what he actually signed up to but that
wasn't what he said
he was going to sign up to that's my
point so when mr johnson declared on
december the 24th
we've taken back control of every jot
and tittle
whatever that means every jot and tittle
of our regulations
in a way that's complete and unfettered
that once again wasn't true is it
northern ireland
is very much fettered by its obligation
to abide by the rules
of the eu single market at least for the
next
four years again that's fact
look what we have managed to do we have
managed to leave
the european union as one united kingdom
northern ireland alongside the rest of
the united kingdom
of great britain and and of course and
northern ireland and what we have
achieved
is something that most people thought
was unachievable we've managed to do it
uh with with very little uh obstruction
on trade
we've managed to do it as one without a
hard border on on the island of ireland
and now we're moving forward with that
with a deal which allows us to to create
a new
relationship of friendship and
cooperation something that we can build
on
as we move forward this time a year ago
this time two years ago people were
questioning whether brexit would even
happen the fact that we've got it across
the line the fact that we have now left
in fact we've now left the transition
period
with as good a deal as we have for
british business and yes businesses
in northern ireland who actually i think
would have the best of both worlds
uh is something i think they should be
cheered and not something i think we
should be
uh critical about do you think that
enhances the
reputation of the the government and the
prime minister when you just break a
promise which you made to um
with the dup in northern ireland and
just brush over it
you think other countries don't notice
that i think what
enhances the position of the british
government is
is is a demonstration that's able to
achieve what we have achieved
in peacefully uh and with uh with a good
intention
leaving the european union with this
trade deal something which as i keep
saying
people only a year ago were saying was
impossible
and the threat and the threat to walk
away from the northern ireland deal and
breach international law in the process
not only produced outrage in britain and
europe but also in the u.s
where you talk about uh the need for a
u.s trade deal and
getting together with the new biden
administration it hasn't exactly
enhanced mr johnson's reputation
with that incoming administration has it
well
well look what that threat achieved was
the result of our getting
in the northern ireland protocol agreed
and the uh eventual deal
uh with the european union uh uh
the threat no longer stands because the
deal has no longer been done i supported
the government all the way through in
its position in negotiating
and its uh and its tactics and trying to
get a deal that works for ourselves
and the european union and what we were
uh talking about was something which
other countries in the world have done
on numerous occasions of course it sat
uncomfortably with me the talk of
breaking international law but we we
very much hoped it wouldn't come to that
and it hasn't we managed to uh come to
an agreement come
to a deal which i think is good for
everybody concerned yes and so shoddy
was it that the government's chief law
officer had to resign in protest
uh
with britain after this really well well
the european union did
yeah yeah but after that they got what
they wanted out of the deal
look the government was was playing
hardball as
many countries do when they're
negotiating complex international
agreements and
and indeed germany has done uh on
occasion in the past the chief law
officer
resigned on principle and of course i
respect that the idea that britain would
uh break into a national war however it
has not come to that
uh which is a very good thing in my eyes
a deal was done
and now i think we're in a very good
position to move forward and as i say
build on a relationship a long-standing
relationship between allies and friends
as we move forward and the shared
objectives that we have
between ourselves and the european union
promoting democracy promoting the rule
of law combating climate change
championing
free trade all the things that we share
with the european union that this deal
will allow us to continue to work with
them to achieve
let's talk about those teething problems
which you mentioned do those include
empty shelves in some of the
supermarkets in northern ireland which
the government described as teething
problems
that hasn't done anything to pacify the
democratic unionist party to jeffrey
donaldson
the leader at westminster said the
northern ireland protocol had ruined
trade in northern ireland it was an
insult to our intelligence to talk of a
teething problem
his colleague ian paisley said the
province had been screwed
over by mr johnson this was another part
of the deal that wasn't properly thought
out wasn't it
well these are teething problems the
government is working very closely with
the
uh the holiers and uh businesses that
are seeking to transport goods across
the irish sea into north island to make
sure that the scenes that we saw
in early january of empty shells and
supermarkets are not
repeated there is no reason for them to
be any uh shortage of foodstuffs in
northern ireland and so
uh michael grove has said chancellor
dutch lancaster has said that he is
engaging
uh closely with the businesses concerned
to ensure that these situations do not
arise again
you say there's no reason you say
there's no reason why there should be an
empty shell but there were plenty of
warnings not least from the national
audit office back in november
when it slammed the government for
shortage of customs brokers
unprepared border sites failure to build
enough capacity and new custom software
you reap what you sow don't you
well look there are obviously teething
problems we are now
40 to 50 sorry i missed that question
it's a failure to plan properly it's not
a teething problem it's a failure to
plan properly and you were warned about
it
well i think what is clear is that we
didn't know the situation
uh regarding a trade deal until at the
very last minute was the
20 it was christmas eve i believe that
we announced a deal
uh with the european union so the fact
that people are criticizing the
unpreparedness
of either the government or the european
union customs officials in terms of
uh getting everything up and running is
a little bit unfair there were
you signed the northern ireland protocol
considerably earlier than christmas eve
we are aware that there are issues in
terms of foodstuffs getting across the
irish into northern ireland and what we
none of us wants to see ever again are
empty shells and supermarkets within the
united kingdom so
uh we are very sure and certain that the
uh steps that we have taken since the
early weeks of january to make sure that
they
uh good stuff get to northern ireland uh
mean that we will not be seeing those
scenes which nobody wants to see
happen in the near future mr barry it
was staggering to read in mr johnson's
christmas eve speech that his brexit
deal means
certainty for business from financial
services to our world leading
manufacturers in fact there's no
certainty at all for britain's financial
services is there because
there's almost nothing in the deal about
them and mr johnson himself regretted
that
at least didn't he said the deal had
failed to meet his ambitions in that
sector
so certainly no certainty there in fact
the only certainty
was came in the losses that hit the city
of london on the first full day of
trading this year
i think what the prime minister was
saying on the 24th of december
was that what this deal does is
guarantee certainty for where we are
heading
as the united kingdom and where our
relationship will be with the european
union so that business can now
go on and plan for the next few years
and indeed decades
as we move forward that is what the
prime minister was saying well hardly
encouraging signs worthy nearly 6
billion euros worth of eu
share dealing shifted right out of
london on that first day of trading
and into other european capitals the
chief executive of aki exchange said
it's not big bang it's bang and it's
gone the city has lost
its european share business that's a
hefty cut in tax receipts for the
government and somehow that prediction
didn't make it
its way into the brexiteers uh
prospectus did it before the referendum
there are obviously areas of the deal
that may maybe we we might have
liked to have gone further and we might
may have liked to have seen financial
services
uh included uh in terms of the overall
aspect of the deal but what we achieved
was what people
nobody expected hardly anybody anyway
expects us to be able to achieve and the
prime minister says we achieved
certainty for business that's exactly
what we did
businesses now know what our
relationship with the continent of
europe will be for the next few years
and probably
the next few decades and that gives us a
very good place to start mr barry they
don't
know they don't know because the eu
hasn't accepted
the equivalence between um britain's
financial services
and its own so you have no idea whether
they're going to do that
and perhaps the only certain thing is
what uh the office of budget
responsibility
can i just finish can i just finish the
yes the office of budget responsibility
says you're going to take a four percent
hit
to gdp over the next 10 years that's the
only certainty
that's coming up well i think the only
certainty is that anybody making
economic predictions at the minute is
is bound to be uh about to be proven
wrong in some respects indeed i can't
even remember the last time the obr got
a prediction that was
in any way near uh correct would last 10
years for the united kingdom but
the fact is if the european union do not
accept equivalents uh for
uh the british financial sector then
they would be coming off their nose
despite their faith the relationship
between the london stock exchange
frankfurt and all the rest
uh is deep and enduring and will
continue to be so and i look forward
to the european union accepting that
accepting equivalence
is beneficial not just to us but to them
as well
well it's good of you to tell them
what's beneficial for them but they may
well have other ideas about it as they
have done
throughout the negotiations all this
comes as a new study from the london
school of economics predicts british
exports to the eu will
nose dive by around a third over the
next 10 years with total uk trade
falling by 13
those dire predictions are backed up by
figures for last year compiled by the
financial times
and released in december they show that
uk goods exports have lagged behind peer
countries in 2020
in both the eu and other markets look
look
we always promised very hard to build up
our manufacturing
uh sector and to increase exports from
the united kingdom but these
dire predictions uh from the london
school of economics from the financial
times and others
were these are the exactly the same
people that were predicting dire
consequences on the day that we left
the european union uh last year they
were predicting the lights would go out
and somehow britain would become a
pariah state
murdered in the north sea that's
absolutely not the case this year we're
demonstrating hosting
uh cop20 sits hosting uh the g7 that we
are a leading player on the world stage
and we will continue to be so working
with our friends and allies
in the european union yes of course we
want to export more yes of course we
want to move ahead of italy again and
exporting to united states america and
should we be building more
uh british things in the united kingdom
absolutely and we should be selling them
abroad but it's not just it's not just
particularly it's not predictions mr
bowie in the six months to october
u.s imports from the uk fell by almost
30 percent that's almost twice the drop
recorded by germany and spain
so there's clearly nervousness about
trading with britain
at the moment isn't there well i hope
that people i hope the
countries in the world and companies
across the world overcome
uh that nervousness in the months ahead
as they see
the relationship blossom between
ourselves and the european union they
see
that there is nothing but nothing has
changed within the united kingdom in
terms of
our ambition to be an outward facing
exporting free trading nation and that
is
exactly what we are going to be focusing
on uh as we move out of this
uh period of the pandemic and all the
rest of it over the next few months and
years
isn't it a fact that having sovereignty
is
little more than a myth as former deputy
prime minister michael hesseltein said
recently
sovereign in charge control regained
none of that creates a single job one
pounds worth of investment
or any rise in living standards that's
what he said he's right isn't he and
that's what the figures already are
showing
well look there's an argument about
whether a country is sovereign or not
and there's an argument about how you
develop the economy and create jobs
uh we can do both at the same time
britain has achieved sovereignty it's
achieved independence
from the european union now our focus is
on building up our economy recovering
from coronavirus
creating jobs and as the prime minister
would say leveling up
across the united kingdom and that is
very much where our focus is now the two
are not interlinked just because one has
become sovereign does not mean that one
is suddenly
going to succeed in every other aspect
and we
we are determined to you didn't get your
waters back you got a 25
quota transfer over the next five years
far less than you originally demanded
and your fishermen are now accusing you
rightly of betrayal aren't they
why because you made promises you
couldn't stop i understand i understand
the frustration
i represent the constituency of the
northeast scotland i represent i
understand very much
the concerns in the fishing industry and
yes we've got a 25
uh transfer over the next
five years that gives us the opportunity
to build up our fishing industry
so that in five years time when we
become an
independent coastal state taking our
seat uh
at the table to negotiate access quotas
and all the rest of it with the european
union with norway with iceland
that we will be doing that uh on the
same basis as all the others so yes i
understand the frustration
in the fishing industry it's not what
they expected on day one
but we have now the prospect in five
years time of becoming an independent
sovereign coastal state
and that is what we are working towards
now we can build up our our home fishing
industry
be ready to reap the rewards of the sea
of opportunity that lies with us
from 2025 onwards it wasn't what they
expected because it wasn't what you told
them to expect it was never going to
happen that way was it because some of
that sovereignty
that you won through leaving the
european union
you bargained away in the deal didn't
you as you always do
with sovereignty you bargained bits away
sovereignty is bargained by britain's
membership
of the wto the world health organization
nato it's not an absolute is it
sovereignty
no it's not but what the british people
voted it was sold as an absolute it was
sold as an absolute
what the british people voted for in
june 2016 was to
have control over their borders and
their laws
and where british money british
taxpayers money
was indeed being spent and that is what
we have achieved through leaving the
european union and leaving the
transition
agreement with uh this deal and in five
years time
british fishermen will have control over
more stocks of fish than they have ever
had since we
first joined the european community as
it was in the 1970s it was only then by
the way that the european union even
created
their common fisheries policy so yes we
are going to have to bide our time and
be patient for the next five years but
what that does do
is allow us to invest over a hundred
million pounds in building up
our fishing industry so that it can reap
the rewards
when the day comes that we take our seat
as an independent
uh outward-looking coastal states uh in
the negotiations with european norway
well your clients and your businesses
aren't buying that the national
federation of fishermen's organizations
told mr johnson recently
it would be much better if you with
humility and honesty
that word again humility and honesty
conceded that you tried but failed
rather than implying that you'd handed
us the keys of our liberation
when you haven't so there's a long way
to go to convince
your clients that you've actually got
what you say you've got
because they're not buying it now
they're not buying it
there is a long way to go i get that and
i get the frustration i speak to them
on a near daily basis so i understand
what we have to do to make sure that we
regain the trust
of fishermen and the fishing industry in
the united kingdom but
uh it's a far better thing that we have
got this deal across the line so that we
are still able to trade and sell
scottish and british fish in the
european union that would otherwise
be the case 25 horse transfer by the way
far above what the eu were initially
asking for and full control in five
years time given we have been a member
of this common fisheries policy which
has
some people say it ruined the british
fishing industry over the last 40 years
i think isn't
too small a price to pay and we will
reap the benefits in a few years time
all right andrew bowie it's been great
having you on conflict zone thank you
very much indeed
thank you very much
[Music]
you